welcome to day two so we are heading to
Park City live that's where we've been
doing all the interviews that's where
all the shows a bin and I think our
first interview up is slash you have
like your production company you know
you're still doing music and you're
going on tour here's how I believe in no
we couldn't have from now oh wow so you
have any what's your favorite place to
tour I get asked a lot I mean I just
like touring and I mean there's
everything has its own charm I mean I
love doing Europe I love being in South
America we're gonna go to Asia which is
always slash now next up is zoe kravitz
who i actually I just connect all the
dots
she seems Christina and diver insurgents
coming out March something in March
insurgent yes a little touch and try
section which is basically this is kind
of like my dream come true
you guys I'm excited and these are like
the hi cameras is the c100 mark I'm
losing my mind I think this might be as
might be my next camera
fifteen we're at Sunday it's 2015 and
I'm here with Matisyahu and you just got
here
yep yesterday we were performing a
little bit tonight and we're performing
tomorrow night a little something so I
have a music video coming out that I
heard yes I do it's called it's a video
for hard way
and it's kind of a little bit of a
different direction a lot of my other
songs like one day or king without a
crown are more kind of ideological songs
I'm dealing with more like a bigger idea
or a bigger picture and the song is more
about my own personal relationships and
my own kind it's a lot more intimate and
I'm really really happy about the song
the video so we're about to head back
over to Sundance and we're heading back
to Park City Live which is basically
where we've spent the entire time that
we've been here in that building Diplo
was performing and the I so you know by
following Diplo on Twitter or on
Instagram I found out that he likes
twerking twerking and booty to learn a
lot from Instagram
it's extremely way past my bedtime pitar
has kept me out quite late we just
thought it'd blow actually we need to
watch your mouth sir we don't swear here
so why don't you know dowsing anyway it
was awesome I he called him a bunch of
you would've liked work and do splits
and like having a comfortable in this
one situation that's happening here but
it was fun now Fatah is making me go to
yet another for Rio I mean kids lives
200 oh my god it surely cross the stream
here we might as well I mean it's what
what time is it
it ends it's moot I'm Jack 139 yeah so
we're heading back home tomorrow so this
is the end of the vlog unless something
actually really cool happens and I
decide to go mix alright turn up I had a
lot of Red Bulls day I think I have a
drinking Red Bull since 3 p.m.
do the math right